Наймолодший міський голова в Україні 25-річний Олег Вольський більшості зі своїх нинішніх підлеглих годиться в сини,
а декому навіть в онуки. Попри це колеги звертаються до молодого керівника не інакше як Олеже Івановичу.
Нас було 10 кандидатів і я був серед них наймолодшим.
Дуже так було збоку помітно, коли казали "Він ще молодий!Куди він іде?
Йому ще зарано!Він не впорається!" І до ейджизму я ставився з іронією.
Мені навпаки було приємно, що є такі розмови.
У мерське крісло Олег потрапив мало не з університетської лави.
Вже третій рік він навчається в аспірантурі одного з львівських вишів,
а ще встиг сім місяців попрацювати у столиці-уміністерстві фінансів.
З Києва до Жовкви повернувся, не вагаючись. Браку досвіду для нової роботи Олег не відчуває.
За час роботи в мінфіні я побачив, як працюють місцеві бюджети по цілій країні,
я побачив кращі практики, я побачив, як збираються на місцях податки, як вони формуються,  які є видаткові частини
і,власне,тепер я з цим досвідом іду працювати до себе в громаду.
У нас 29 років працювали люди, які мали великий досвід. У нас вони працювали по 10-15 років на керівних посадах,
але усі знають що наша громада не є в кращому стані.У нас дуже багато мешканців незадоволені їхньою роботою.
І тому тут є перевага молодості над досвідом.
Центром Жовкви молодому голові нині спокійно не пройти. До нього повсякчас
звертаються місцеві мешканці-давні знайомі та нові колеги.
Олега Вольського у Жовкві і довколишніх селах добре знають. Молодий чоловік народився у цьому районі і ніколи не лишався осторонь його проблем.
Як волонтер возив допомогу на схід, організовував міський молодіжний простір, допомагав з реставрацією місцевого замку.
А ще саме Олег був ініціатором створення ОТГ, яку тепер сам і очолив.
До громади,окрім міста Жовква,увійшли ще 14 селищних рад. Тепер амбітному молодому чоловікові належить
розпорядитися бюджетом у 270 мільйонів гривень, аби забезпечити комфорт і добробут 35 тисяч мешканців громади.
Реформа децентралізації дає ширші повноваження, зокрема більші є бюджети і більші є можливості для розвитку.
Але реформа децентралізації вона дає і більшу відповідальність,  адже тепер у сфері підпорядкування територіальної громади є
освіта, медицина, культура, тобто такі ключові галузі.
Олег не приховує-проблем у громаді вистачає. Здебільшого вони типові для України: погані дороги, мало робочих місць, квола медицина у селах.
Однак є і суто локальні, як от облуплені фасади старих історичних будинків на центральній міській площі.
Ми бачимо, що місцями є приватні підприємці, що займають перші поверхи,
є місцеві мешканці, які хочуть долучитися до реставрації, у цьому зацікавлені і ми.
Я думаю, що спільним шляхом партнерства ми зможемо відновлювати ці фасади.
Але будемо намагатися включати і в державну програму, в місцеві програми.
З цього питання треба починати, адже це візитівка нашої громади.
Велику ставку Олег Вольський робить саме на туризм. З нього, каже, можна отримувати до 15% прибутку в бюджет,
адже Жовква має багату історію, а дорога до Львова чи сусідньої Польщі займає не більше години.
І в докарантинні часи чимало туристів приїжджали подивитися старе місто.
Тепер очільник громади хоче, щоб поїхали і до сіл.
Ми бачимо, наскільки тут гарна природа і наскільки тут гарний ландшафт.
Тут насправді є великий потенціал рекреаційний, відпочинковий. Сюди вже потрошку приглядаються інвестори.
Є мета розвивати ці території як відпочинкові зони.
Однак поки одні села Жовківської громади вже розбудовують інфраструктуру і чекають на туристів,
дістатися в інші-завдання не з легких. Місцями дороги в ОТГ лиш нагадують автошляхи.
Але далі,от ми бачимо,починаються насправді великі вибоїни
Для бюджету громади зробити капітальний ремонт такої дороги-непосильнівитрати. Однак і на це у молодого голови є план.
Можливо, на наступний рік нам вдасться написати проєкт та залучити кошти для ремонту цього покриття дорожнього.
Потребує, власне, фінансування як з державного бюджету, обласного, так і з нашого місцевого.
Тут є великі території, є можливості до залучення інвестицій, до побудови підприємств,
але інвестор не хоче сюди йти,поки тут не буде дороги.
Тим часом жителі громади, давши молодому кандидату кредит довіри,
тепер хочуть разючих змін і прискіпливо за ним спостерігають.
У першу чергу побачимо, якою буде реакція на підвищення цін на газ, бо це кожного стосується.
Хай він не розслабляється. Справа в тому, що це ж не мер міста.
Це в майбутньому ОТГ, а це ж села і все. Його команді буде дуже тяжко.
Треба молодим давати дорогу! У них енергії більше, ініціативи,
в голові і то, і то, і то. Хай працюють, хай щось роблять.
А коли буде робити? Коли буде мати 50? Ні, то все відпадає!
Наразі ж Олег Вольський ще не може взятися за вирішення більшості проблем,
бо насамперед має пропрацювати бюджет новоствореної ОТГ
та сформувати команду з майже дев’яноста людей.
Зараз навколо мене точаться такі інтриги, що можна писати книгу чи знімати серіал.
Я одразу після виборів побачив, як усе змінилося і як люди почали будувати
містки до мене і містки до міської ради. Це все дуже збоку так виглядало дивно.
Я до цього всього ставлюся з іронією до різних інтриг, адже я розумію,
що основою має бути"господарка"і розвиток цієї громади.
Найбільше, чого я боюся, вступаючи на цю посаду, це не підвести жодного
з тих людей, які поставили галочку в бюлетені за мене. Жовква побудована за концепцією ідеальних міст доби ренесансу.
Я мрію, щоб про нашу громаду говорили як в Україні, так і в світі з приставкою ідеальна громада.